hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well okay so if you
want have a community get the divine of
social roles in some ways there are
certain things that every community
needs in order to be a functioning
community and play don't gives you a
very idealized version of the city and
you don't necessarily have to buy into
this in order to see what he's talking
about here's the ideal city that he
describes you have these people they
call the guardians or the rulers and
they exercise precisely that sort of
function they they're in charge they
make the big decisions you know about
the economy or where to put in roads or
you know what laws to enact or those
sorts of things when there's when
there's problems between people
presumably they would be carrying out
that other judicial you know decisions
here in cases all that stuff they would
also be in charge of education at least
of themselves and their own classes you
can think of these like in today's
contemporary terms maybe being something
like you know combination of mayors and
council members and city planners
educators and all the sort of stuff you
only want to class Plato's a little bit
vague about exactly what these are going
to be like he's talking about ancient
Greece so it doesn't translate perfectly
to it it's art but you get the idea
right so we have that class and then we
have another class you have what he
calls the auxiliaries or the lesser
Guardians and these basically translate
to be what nowadays for the most part we
would call the army and the police I
guess also the Virgin Mary you know
because you need somebody to protect
your shipping trading so what do they do
they protect the city from outside
threats because with any community
unless you have you know perfectly
peaceful world you're gonna have some
outside threats some people if you have
stuff people will want your stuff and
you have to be able to protect yourself
and if you're a city you have to be able
to protect your citizens right sometimes
it actually means like you know going
off and making alliances or going to war
or doing these other things hopefully
that somebody else's ground then you're
on what about believes well you know you
also to keep order within the city
human beings are liable to do all sorts
of wrong things to each other right yeah
one of the functions of police is to try
to maintain order that's why you see
them parades for example are they there
just cuz you know cops like looking at
and spectacles and people give them the
nice seats no they are just in case
something happens they can re-establish
order and we could probably think of
other groups that that fit in with this
as well I mean insofar as you're dealing
with like internal problems that aren't
necessarily caused by
human beings in their decisions but more
by the natural environment what about
firefighters they they would probably
fit into that that class as well maybe
America emergency responders could be
argued to fit into that class then you
get everyone else and everybody in this
this polis or city of Plato has a job
let they go how do you think about it
that's a lot right everybody does
something it may not be necessarily
something
well matches but they do something even
within the household it's an awful lot
of work to maintain the household right
somebody goes off to earn money and the
other person stays home in the house
duty counters is a good partnership if
the person who's staying in the house
just sits around watches TV all day what
are they supposed to be doing cleaning
that's a big thing things get really
dirty fast you know what else bills like
they think they might actually be
carrying out those financial
arrangements because I might do some
cooking or shopping shopping as a pain
right anybody who's done shopping that
can take a whole day then you probably
or that or you know you could be like a
mystery shopper I would be I've done
I've done stuff kind of like there is
something rewarding to I was lucky
enough
with my kids I got to sing home about a
good portion of the time I do I don't
like going to the stores though because
it takes a lot of time anyway so we have
all sorts of jobs right I don't want to
get too out of traffic it's but we've
all other functions and photo things you
know everybody else they're not as
important to the running of the city
into the proper arrangement of it they
do supply some really important things
you don't have two people producing food
now you're gonna die right do you don't
have people producing clothing unless
you're living in a very tropical
environment you're gonna die do you know
people building houses do you have
people maintaining the sewers if you get
big enough if you don't have people
actually buying and selling things
you're gonna have some real problems and
when the things work the best in a city
when everybody sticks to their task
because each task in this this
tripartite scheme each task has its own
set of importance and can each task be
done well or poorly the other ways you
can screw this up just a trivial example
right let's take traffic planning not
even City Planning just travel planning
9wi here it's nice how about those
stoplights could those be set up in such
a way as to really irritate you oh yes
so they you you you're backed up in
traffic and it turns green and now
everybody goes and by the time you get
to the next stoplight maybe 500 yards
it's right yeah and that's you know that
isn't that's a bad plan
that's what's really bad planning it's
like those stupid where it's like people
are emerging from the right in any of
you
emerging from the left merge bought like
exit to the left yeah I used to have to
do something like that every single day
but they did it twice in a row never
really terrible there are some people
that are good city planners and there
are some people that are bad city was
thinking about judges - there's good
judges and they had judges this is kind
of trivial example as well it doesn't
fit Plato's thing a little bit break now
in the NFL there's like a huge you know
fir and outcry because these replacement
officials are screwing up calls people
get upset about that kind of thing right
why do they get it so good because
there's standards for good performance
and their standards for bad performance
and they affect people's lives
yeah this relates to a bad driving
comment like literally coming off an
off-ramp this guy decided to stop in
traffic and then back up the way that he
came and I I've never seen that happen
in my life yeah I've actually seen that
before
I've never any to her that wasn't just
him it was a car after him I did it -
good idea
well no no was it a female driver that's
less of an issue about who's planning
the city you know there's that old
expression Kevin I just totally fool
group that's somebody's screwing up
those and that's where like the cops are
covered right hopefully no
all right yeah yeah but I'm feeling the
cops like encourage it like if I tell
there's like just four quarters like
these center part of town and it's
normally gets backed up from the 3
o'clock 5 o'clock but you can't drive
through it takes forever and then they
set up with Walgreens in the middle of
it and the Walgreens only exit is out of
onto the four corners and like when I
went into planning a lot of people like
had concerns about it and the police for
the first two bakit and it's a nightmare
okay planner they're enforcing event
planning then their disability yeah by
first thing like I meant more like
they're actually out on the streets
enforcing the laws they are they're
everywhere they require the planning
process they would be acting like the
garbage
we're going together yeah I mean ideally
the the police the soldiers they're
actually maintaining order they're not
preying on the people they're not
screwing things up worse and then you
know everybody else
they also climb order functions as well
now Plato thinks that this is analogous
to two parts of your personality or your
solve this this gets a little bit you
know enough of a stretch you know are
you really like a city do you have
multiple personalities inside it's not
exactly that is that what he's saying is
that you have dimensions you can think
of or parts of you do different things
and corresponding to the Guardians would
be what he actually calls a smallest
party which is your or your rationale
partners
this is the part of you that's actually
for the most part being concentrated on
here in college
we're supposed to be developing here
you're in tonight right you're learning
things you're that's the whole process
of education that's not all that
education actually consists in to but
that's a large part of what it consists
in and then you know corresponding to
this you have booty calls desire or
appetites and then you have something in
between this is kind of an interesting
thing to play out you've got this thing
that in Greek is called thumos which is
a little bit difficult to translate
which is why in different translations
we use words like passion spirit and
another point in time another
translation uses the term energy and I
know I don't mean to you know use this
in like a physics kind of sense just
like being energetic and each of these
parts of your soul does different things
your intellect what does that do cuz a
lot of stuff right
we have intellectual curiosity you want
to know about something when you go on
google and you look it up that's
probably your intellect driving into
things unless of course it's like trying
to figure out how to probably your
appetites or desires this middle part of
the soul is concerned with things like
respect self-esteem comparison of you to
other people how you view yourself how
other people view you it's also
concerned with questions about justice
or anger things like that
now Plato thinks that you can associate
these with the different people involved
he also thinks that you can associate
these with different nationalities know
these nationalities are all long gone so
this is kind of a abstract exercise I'm
putting this up the Greeks have this
idea it's sort of like you know the
Goldilocks idea you know we got too hot
too cold just right they have this sort
of idea about other nationalities
everybody else you know the Greeks call
it right they'd work for them Greek it's
Bob literally barbarians right and what
did they call other people barbarians
well because they didn't speak Greek and
you know the legend is they called them
Barbara because they thought that when
they're talking all that is here is the
bomb
and they divided barbarians up in the
different groups though to the north
were those you know kind of reckless get
in trouble want to get in fights all the
time peoples who had occasionally invade
you know they live out on the open and
ride horses and make all sorts of you
know feasts and you know these are the
sins and the Celts and people like that
and those people were dominated by sumos
this is the sort of energy this is
willingness to like get involved be very
passionate about things not with
intellect and then there were the people
you know to the south and to the south
of the Greeks was you know great old
civilization of Egypt massive commercial
civilization to their wet to their East
sorry was all of the while eventually
the Persians yeah there's also the
Phoenicians even in the Persian Empire
and these these people were like really
into Commerce and they associated that
with the appetites why do you engage in
commerce and money-making to satisfy
demand and then the Greeks of course who
are they associated with intellect yes
and so we have played up says this he
puts us in Socrates mouth does that mean
that the Greeks were all you know super
you know smart people who never got
themselves in trouble with this done it
just takes a little bit of reading Greek
history day that wasn't the case we're
all of our barians like that no but you
can you can associate this with certain
types of people you can say that within
certain groups some of these would
predominate if you were to go into a
police precinct today do you think that
you would find more people who are
primarily intellectual primarily you
know commercial or something like that
where people who are willing to get into
fights and you know scrap or let's say
we take the military the military
attracts a certain kind of person and
doing that kind of job should actually
you know maintain that right so these
different parts they fulfill different
functions your intellect what do you
need it for you don't have it you're
probably going to be in a lot of trouble
because something else is going to call
the shots what do you need you're into
that war thinking things out right
figuring things out then you you have to
decide on figuring out what to do next
all those sorts of things you actually
do need your appetites if you didn't
desire to eat what would happen here
yeah you and your body would start you
didn't desire to drink you would you
would die of thirst if nobody here ever
decided they're not decided if nobody
here ever desired to have sex what
happened in the oven race it would dive
into this would be the last generation
or I've actually the little babies that
are here right now it would be the last
generation you guys would be the second
the last generation these designers that
we have they fulfill some sort of
purpose can they what we'll come back to
that alone what about this part do you
need this part of you this part that
sometimes gets angry or when you feel
like you've been wrong takes takes
offense at that do you need that you
know some people think that you don't
Plato does them can do sort of aerosol
some people say hi you want to get rid
of that because more calm and found it
but yeah you're right we do need that
otherwise what's gonna happen here
people walk all over you you know so you
need all three parts of us can make it
out of whack
that's where virtues and vices are